I'm a homeschool mom, and I wanna talk about this video.
I tried to stitch it, but it kept all the music on,
and it wouldn't let my voice over be heard.
I don't know. It was really weird.
So I'm gonna tag the original creator so you can see it.
But this was basically the whole video,
so pause to read. I wanted to talk about this because I feel like
within the homeschool community,
there is this innate criticism of public education,
especially depending on where you live.
One of the factors that caused us to be homeschool parents
is we don't live in a fantastic public education system area.
Um, it's better than most in the state,
but the state itself is pretty low down on the levels
as far as, like,
the states are concerned.
I think we are No. 42 in the country for public education systems.
They always talk about homeschooling as a humongous privilege.
It is a responsibility as well,
but it is a humongous privilege of time and resources
to be able to homeschool your kids.
There is no reason
that our country should ever get rid of a public education system,
not just for kids who cannot afford private or homeschool educations,
but also because every citizen of this country
should be guaranteed an education by our government.
Now, we can have criticisms on how that's done,
on policy, on administrative issues,
on what subjects and how the curriculum works.
We We can have disagreements on that,
but you cannot have a basic disagreement with me
to talk about the dissolution or. Yeah,
the dissolution of the public education system
and have me agree with you,
even as a homeschool mom. I have no intention
necessarily of homeschooling all the way through high school.
Maybe we will, maybe we won't.
But public education is something that so many families rely on.
Not just working parents, but kids in, um,
aggressive households, kids who need a solid meal.
I still don't know why we can't be supplying all the school supplies
and lunches for kids
in our public school system.
There is no reason that the United States. Oh,
I also take issue with the fact that it is tax based
and therefore innately classist.
The quality of education that you are gonna receive as a country.
So in my opinion, it actually should be more socialized than it is now.
However, um,
homeschool parents need to get a little bit off their high horse
because they think that they're doing something superior
and realize that what you may be doing
maybe superior to the public education system.
However,
that public education system is a life raft for a lot of families,
and it is also a fantastic option that we have in this country.
We are going further and further away from our government
providing anything of, like,
substantial difference to our lives.
Um, socialized healthcare,
medical services. We.
We are privatizing Everything.
And if we privatize education,
we are just. Oh,
we are leaving so many people stranded
because we've already done that with the healthcare system.
I just think it's just a dangerous conversation to have.
You can criticize something and still believe in its existence. Okay.
You can criticize something and want it done better
and still support its existence.
Okay. Thank you.